Кістки, прикраси і навіть взуття.
Тут у прямому сенсі слова докопалися до історії.
Це місце масового поховання євреїв, розстріляних фашистами.
Могилу виявили під час будівельних робіт у центрі Бреста.
Під час німецької окупації в часи Другої світової війни
цей район був єврейським гетто.
Десятки тисяч людей були страчені в Бресті і довкола міста.
Будмайданчик нині закритий для громадськості,
у тому числі і для дослідниці історії Ірини Лавровської.
Вона зверталася з проханням припинити тут
будівельні роботи і вважає, що тут слід звести
меморіальний парк, а не житловий комплекс.
- Не можна жити на місці масової екзекуції.
Половину населення міста протягом кількох днів знищили.
Половину мешканців міста.
Цей біль продовжує існувати і не дасть нам спокою,
поки ми самі не навчимося поважати те, що тут сталося.
За розкопки відповідає спеціальний батальйон білоруської армії.
Більшість цих молодих солдатів проходять військову службу.
Вони знайшли загалом залишки понад 1100 тіл,
які мають перепоховати на місцевому цвинтарі.
І одразу поруч із цією масовою могилою
продовжують будівництво сучасного житлового комплексу.
Це прибутковий проект: один квадратний метр тут
коштує майже удвічі більше від середньої ринкової ціни в Бресті.
Міська влада стверджує, що фундамент будівлі
не зачепить масового поховання і що тут встановлять меморіальну дошку.
- Житловий комплекс - це більш правильно, це те,
що потрібно місту, щоб тут було доглянуте місце.
Тут були такі непривабливі будинки.
Дуже хотілося б, щоб тут був нарешті порядок та краса.
Це не вперше, коли будівельники знаходять кістки
під час будівництва в історичному центрі.
А що думають про це самі мешканці міста?
- Будувати там будинки, мені здається,
дуже нерозумно. Треба поставити пам'ятник.
- Галас, який піднявся… Треба з нього виходити,
як то кажуть, цивілізовано. Зрештою, майже всі
міста Європи стоять на рештках людей.
Ірина сповнена рішучості побачити місце
масової могили на власні очі, перш ніж тут
закатають дороги й облаштують двір.
Одна її знайома має прямий вид зі свого вікна
на будмайданчик. Вона каже, що проект будівництва
свідчить про те, що можновладці не вивчили уроків минулого.
Білоруську владу раніше вже критикували
за будівництво на єврейських кладовищах.
- У цій країні поважають лише пам'ять
про радянських захисників Брестської фортеці,
про військових, які зі зброєю в руках боролися
з іншою такою ж тоталітарною країною. Ось це поважають.
Будівельна компанія сказала DW, що
житловий комплекс буде закритим. Натомість
міська влада нині запевняє, що зробить територію
відкритою для громадськості.